Gina claire de son nom catherine est
créatrice de mode depuis 17 ans de son
père couturier elle a obtenu l'amour du
métier mais a l'adapter au fil des ans
pour développer aujourd'hui ses propres
créations une adaptation qu'elle a su
imposer en dépit d'un contexte pas
toujours
facile d'abord il voulait pas que je fe
je fasse la couture Paron est tr sœurs
il y a une qui est professe de couture
il y a une autre qui qui a travaillé
aussi avec lui et qui travaill avec moi
bon on a trois filles dans le dans le
métier quand moi je lui ai dit que je je
m'arrêtais pour faire la couture elle
m'a dit non tout de suite il m'a dit non
c'est un métier trop dur on va pas
gagner
d'argent beaucoup de choses et il m'a
mis j'éta très sévère depuis temps
petite très sévère avec nous dans le
métier et moi je lui ai montré que si je
je fais la si je m'arrêtais il fallait
que je faisais quelque chose
d'intéressant je lui montrer que je
voulais faire quelque chose
d'intéressant et il était contre nous à
chaque fois tout le temps tout le temps
tout le temps que je faisais les défilés
tout ça ouais il faut toujours en train
de travailler toujours en train de mais
toujours des critiques négatives parce
qu'il voulait pas qu'on faisait et
aujourd'hui il est content ma fille
mes
filles et c'est en le regardant
travailler que vous avez eu envie de pas
en le dans simplement parce que depuis à
l'âge de 12 ans que dans notre dans
notre famille oui on était on est obligé
on passe pas à la couture parce que moi
je n'ai pas eu de jeudi de de vacances
moi c'était je fais je cousais d'accord
je faisais les bas de pantalons je
faisais les empiècements pour les
costumes je faisais les surgers à la
main je faisais mon p qui de retouche je
n'ai pas eu d'enfance peut-être
peut-être aussi à travers Mami belle je
m'amuse parce que je n'ai pas eu sommet
poupée je n'ai pas eu c'est des vacances
en plus en plus que j'étais l'îné je
suis l'aîné de d'une famille de 7 enfant
je m'occupais de mes sœurs et frères
aussi on Lavit le linge on ctiquer la
maison brosse coco et tout donc en plus
le travail donc c'était une obligation
une exigence de la maison
bon après donc mes sœurs après n pas eu
le même même façon deêtre élevé que que
moi mais c'était obligatoire depuis
l'âge 12 ans je cou mais je partais à
l'école ce que je
regrette c'est que il y a pas assez de
couturière sur la place parce que depuis
le temps qu'on forme il y a pas pouroi
il aurait dû avoir plus que ça je ne
sais pas je pense que c'est après bon
l'apprentissage c'est un c'est une chose
l'école c'est une chose mais entre
l'école et la vie active il manque une
formation c'est prendre en main ces
jeunes là qui ont envie de former envie
de créer une entreprise et leur donner
de la paperasse comme ça là c'est pas ça
c'est le passage
entre l'école et la vie active c'est
cette formation là qui man préparation à
au
métier est-ce queà la Réunion vous
pouvez dire dire maintenant que vous
êtes reconnu ah je sais que j'ai fait
mon travail je sais que je suis reconnu
euh en bien ou en mal de toute façon du
moment qu'on parle de moi c'est donc
j'existe
et j'ai fait que j'ai fais je sais que
je fais un gros travail de communication
et on sait qu'on dit qu'on parle de Gina
CLA on sait que c'est une
coutuille communication couture Gina
claire connaî c'est elle qui organise
chaque année aidée notamment de tous les
membres de sa famille le concours mamie
belle don la dernière édition s'est
déroulé à
Saint-Benoît mamie belle existe depuis
1994 donc j'ai mis ce concours en place
pour rendre un hommage à nos
aînés c'est vrai que ce n'est pas un
concours de beauté mais c'est un
concours qui est basé sur trois critères
donc l'humour les
dynamisme au jour d'aujourd'hui jamais
je je ne pourrais élire la plus jolie
mamie donc c'est un c'est devenu un
événement j'ai deux enfants bon mon
garçon il a 22 ans ma fille 20 ans donc
Véronique elle s'occupe de le son la
chorégraphie ok la chorégraphie
apprendre aux mamie aussi à à à à
marcher à défiler et Laurent lui
s'occupe de la musique de du son et puis
souvent des dossiers de presse j'ai ma
future belle fille aussi qui se qui se
met à la eu comment ça pourer pour les
coyers me tape des coyers elle elle suit
de de près et souvent quand je fais
quelque fois quand je fais mes défilés
quand je n'ai pas de présentateur c'est
elle qui présente ma collection donc
tout le monde est à son rôle de mari mon
mari lui monte les
podium podium don un coup de ma il se
cache se montre pas et donc quelque fois
on sait même pas qui est mon mari il est
là il est parmi nous mais il se montre
pas par rapport aux enfants par rapport
à
moi
des mamies qui elles n'ont pas froid aux
yeux deux obligations pour les
candidates avoir plus de 60 ans et faire
du
sport la raison c'est pour montrer que à
60 ans la mamie éta encore dynamique
qu'elle a encore de l'aisance elle est
pas là simplement pour faire des petits
gâteaux s'occuper des petits enfants
elle s'occupe d'elle elle vit je veux
dire que elle fait des choses qu'elle
aurait dû faire depuis avant et qu'elle
n'a pas pu faire et à cet âge elle peut
ell pe elles peuvent
s'éclater l'organisation ça passe pas le
le jour c'est dire que il y a un temps
de préparation un mois
avant on fait euh on réunit tout le
monde tout le monde se présente donc là
on
on travaille sur les critères de
sélection c'est ce qu'elle doit faire
donc elle repart chez elle et elle
prépare déjà et on se revoit soit dans
la semaine avant le défilé
sur le dimanche avant là on fait une
répète une répétition de A à Z et euh on
je les aide à euh s'il y a des des
choses qui vont pas soit elles font pas
assez pour pour gagner donc je suis là
pour les aider on choisit la musique on
choisit la
chorégraphie et après bien le matin
c'est la Générale enin le matin ou le
oui c'est plutôt le matin donc c'est la
générale donc là on fait le filage elle
touche le podium vraiment elle voit ce
qu'on ce qu'elles font et après il y a
le
concours moi ma ligne de vêtement moi
c'est la femme et je voulais faire un
défilé mais avoir des femmes de 40 ans
et et plus pour présenter mes
collections au lieu d'avoir des jeunes
filles et donc il fallait beaucoup
d'argent je n'ai pas pu donc je me suis
retournée vers les mamis et c'est vrai
que à travers elle je revois ma mamie
parce que ma mamie c'était ma confidente
avec qui je pouvais dire plein de chos
et à travers elle elle remplace elle
remplace donc j'ai plein de petits
secrets donc elle aussi m'apporte
beaucoup de choses et donc bon c'est
devenu comme
ça de MAM belle les mamies elles sont
naturelles elles viennent pas là pour
montrer leur corps elles viennent là
pour défiler elles viennent faire
quelque chose qu'elles n'ont pas pu
faire quand elle était jeune donc tout
ce que je dis tout ce que je je elles
ont enregistré donc elles le font avec
beaucoup d'aisance et la différence avec
les jeunes donc elle pensent elle là-bas
regarde là-bas donc elles
font ell mon elles se montrre quelque
fois elles viennent d'elles-même mais
souvent c'est les petits enfants qui
poussent qui regarde les magazines qui
qui envoient les qui appellent et puis
qui envoi les candidatures de des mamies
ou alors euh très peu sont des mamies
qui se déplacent qui viennent
d'elles-même si il y a il y a mais plus
son sont soutenus par leur famille leurs
petits enfants par les bellesfilles
parce que la belle fille a remarquer que
sa que sa belle-mère est une femme
dynamique qu'elle peut se présenter sur
le podium donc donc les les les
candidature passe comme ça qu 76 ans
vous les voyez après le déf temps
pendant toute l'année
elles reviennent s'il y a pas un défilé
si elles ont pas si euh il y a pas un
spectacle si ell peuvent c'est une
séance de photos s'il y a de la
publicité donc elles sont là elles ont
envie de bouger quand elles ont fait ça
elles ont envie elles se
voi toujours en train de faire d'autres
choses toujours d'autres choses donc
elle viennent me voir si ou alors faire
des interventions dans des dans des dans
des magasin
raconter les histoires et ainsi de suite
donc tout le temps pendant toute
l'année parce que depuis mamie belle qui
coup de
filmcians
méchanceté ah tous les ans tous les ans
il Chang
m quand on fait des
critiques jamais les mêmes si c'est des
critiques positives encore encore machin
mais Gina claire ne s'arrêtera pas en si
bon chemin
au mois d'octobre elle organisera le
concours mamie belle de l'océan indien
mais c'est déjà une autre
histoire
F dans
musi